revenge of the beast is not your average
skateboarder film it's spectacular
cinematography turns the street sport
into an art form
the film's director Sebastian Linda is
an avid skater himself for him it was a
labor of love from start to finish every
Big Horn revenge of the business revenge
of the beasts was meant to take viewers
under the board you can share the
excitement with them when you're flying
through the air so you have to develop a
visual language for others to see
therefore thy life the advantage of
being a skateboarder and a filmmaker is
having a camera path wherever you have
tarmac the camera is totally steady with
no omelets I used to shoot skateboard
videos that way but now it's become my
trademark now when I'm making music
videos I have the board mounted camera
for eighty percent of my shots obstacles
n2l phenom from skateboard Sebastian
Linda is a versatile filmmaker his
resume includes music videos for the
German New Age ambien outfit Schiller
to recordings of his many travels across
the globe
my bus noise tomorrow bus I always want
to outdo myself to do something new and
unconventional to get that inspiration
you have to go out and see something
else it's about finding your feet again
and traveling is essential for that
Banda Scottish movie
when shooting a documentary about a
faith healer and barley he used a
different camera to the one he'd
normally have for promotional films his
equipment and methodology vary according
to the subject the only thing that
remains constant is his style of filming
you didn't believe me that everybody
come up every millimeter of movement
makes a huge difference it's always
about finding the right place and the
right shot which can mean getting dirty
you also have to risk all the equipment
everything you have to work out how it's
going to look with a skater coming
towards me you were jumping over me Ben
pan towards the light in one shot out of
five things to watch Bobby from sake you
light the movement and fly into the Sun
epping Indies on the fleeting
sometimes two busty and Linda edits his
material right where he shot it so he
can upload a trailer version to the
internet there and then
I [ __ ] finsihed 80 I like sharing my
films with the world in the old days you
are limited to a particular TV station
our festival and now there's this
massive global audience when you upload
a film plus a good feedback online I've
only reason songs Sebastian Linda also
uses the internet to finance his films
by a crowdfunding website
he posts clips to keep his benefactors
up-to-date on how his projects are
progressing
crowd funding is national infiniti a
crowdfunding is not only a financial
tool for me it's also a tool for
attracting people to a project in
advance and encouraging them to get
involved so it's marking as well as
funding quasi founding Franklin he's
currently editing the follow-up to his
acclaimed revenge of the beasts this
time with 10 skaters out on the streets
of Indonesia the film also reveals how
the locals young and old alike reacted
to a sport largely unknown in their
country
and soon I might not fit with tomorrow
the great thing about my kind of films
is that you can just live your life with
the camera running the good moments
happen by themselves it's not like going
to work if I look back on our trip I'm
not thinking about the camera I have all
those moments in my head and I forget
the camera there are moments I've
experienced myself or Marty's a moment
in rupee a lift or just finished our
position you might not want to try these
stunts at home but you can experience
the onboard thrills and spills from the
safety of your own screen